Nitric acid is H I know three,
it is a very strong acid so-called oxidizing acid.
It just made by the reaction of nitrogen oxides with water,
and it will dissolve all sorts of metals, as you will see.
Normally it comes,
dissolved in different strengths in water so-called dilute
nitric acid, concentrated nitric acid, and then really strong,
which is called fuming nitric acid, which we don't usually have in the lab.
I was inspired by a book called ignition,
which I heard about from, um, a YouTube comment.
It's really good book, um,
which talks about rocket fuels and mentioned that aniline the
organic compound when mixed with red fuming nitric acid,
which is very concentrated nitric acid spontaneously
burst into flames so-called hypergolic reaction.
So Neil didn't have any red fuming nitric acid, but he had some pretty strong,
concentrated nitric acid. So he tried the reaction in the test tube
And to begin with there was some popping noises,
but then as the aniline warmed up a bit,
it's really dead burst into flames.
Rather smoky plane came out at the top of the test, too.
[Inaudible].
So it rarely looked like a rocket,
not a very big role kit, but it's always satisfying.
When something you read in the book actually happened.
Neil's all time.
Favorite experiment is the reaction between copper and nitric acid.
Neil likes this reaction because you get to different result with
concentrated acid and with dilute acid.
So for the demonstration,
he ran the two reactions side by side with
concentrated next to dilute.
And if you watch,
you'll see the concentrated reaction goes very quickly.
Clouds of Brown gas,
which is the oxide and new to nitrogen dioxide,
and the solution goes deep, greenish color,
violent public.
On the other hand that they use reaction goes a lot slower.
The dilute reaction was in fact so slow that Brady wasn't
convinced anything was happening, but then it did start to get going.
And the solution started going around the pale blue with some
babbling and Neil decided to jazzy start by adding a bit more acid.
So it went rather more concentrated.
And then the reaction went much better.
The solution went to much darker blue,
and there were a few traces of Brown gas.
That is an O two,
but the dilute reaction produces an ow rather than a new tooth.
The reason that Neil likes this reaction so much is that
it was done at school by his school teacher.
And he was the only boy in the class who wrote down the
equations for the two reactions correctly.
We've given you the equations as well, so you can see them. Now,
the third demonstration is based on the English two
Pence coin, which most people call the two P coin,
which used to be made at copper.
And now because copper is become much more expensive is
made out of iron with a coating of copper.
So I had the idea that we could try reacting a
two Pence piece with concentrated nitric acid.
You know, we enjoy destroying coins or at least reacting them
chemically.
But the reason here is that copper dissolves and
concentrated nitric acid. You've just seen it dissolving,
but iron is passive [inaudible] that is,
it reacts a small amount.
And then the surface gets a coating. And the reaction stops.
Neil tried the experiment before Brady arrived in Nottingham
and it worked perfectly copper dissolved,
and he was left with an iron coin that looked more or less the same as the
copper one. You could see all the writing and everything else.
Then when Brady arrived, Neil tried to, to gain,
There was a much small, violent reaction,
Took the coin out. It was really thin.
The picture of her majesty,
the queen was just a vague shadow of her normal self,
almost gone. So Neil decided to do to gain,
and he repeated the experiment.
The reaction happens.
And this time the coin came out just as we
expected copper was gone,
but the iron and the picture of the queen was there.
So there was an extra twist to the second
experiment because Brady was a
bit slow with his equipment to go and put it next to the other.
And let me stop. These Neal took the coin,
waited before rinsing it
while he waited.
Some of the solution of copper nitrate reacted
with the iron and put some clean copper
coating back onto the surface of the coin.
So there was the iron queen with a copper block next to
her, which chemically is quite fun.
But the thing which fascinated me and of
Braden Neal was way on earth.
The first experiment had failed.
Why did the queen dissolve and watching the
video?
I noticed that the volume of nitric acid in the
first experiment was much smaller than in the second experiment.
And I decided that perhaps the solution had got hot and the
passivation reaction only happens with
cold nitric acid. If you have very hot nitric acid,
it can dissolve away the coating and keep reacting with the iron.
So what we decided to do was this was long
after Brady had left Nottingham.
I persuaded Neil to do a control experiment where
he did two reactions side by side with
exactly the same amount of concentrated nitric acid,
but one starting at 50 degrees centigrade and the other room temperature.
And when he dropped in the coins simultaneously,
there was a modest reaction from the cold nitric acid.
But the whole nitric acid really bubbled away,
very vigorously.
And the temperature nearly doubled went from
50 degrees to nearly a hundred degrees.
I think it was 96.
So when he took the coins out,
the one from the cold acid looked really nice.
You could see all of the engravings, but on the other coin,
it was largely dissolved away. And the thin wafer.
So it turned out I was right and I can't
claim to be, have thought of it all myself,
because I did look in the book about the reactions of iron and nitric acid.
And it mentioned cold nitric acid,
but I worked out why that might have been the temperature difference.
But I think this is really quite a good example of how science is
done. You come up with a hypothesis,
an idea of what might happen,
and then you try and experiment with a prediction.
The hot one should react more than the cold one,
and you test it to see if it works. And if it hadn't worked,
we would have had to come up with another explanation.
Professor is nitric acid dangerous. Yes.
And it's very corrosive.
It tends to react with skin to make it yellow.
When I was at school,
when safety regulations were not as strong as they are,
I did a lot of experiments with concentrated nitric
acid.
And my fingers were almost permanently staying yellow
from the nitric acid. And the skin goes yellow.
And after a bit, it peels off,
but it's not a dangerous injury, but nevertheless,
I'd get quite worried. If our students had yellow fingers.
Did your parents ever say anything to you like Martin?
Why are your fingers always yellow? No, they didn't.
And even more important, they didn't think I'd been smoking,
which they might have done.
I think they just thought he's a chemist and this was par for the course.
[Inaudible].